everybody
wow
one day
me
thank you
oh
nice
party in america right now
and we get my whole town world
tower can i hear you say world town
wall town is that working yet
oh
is
is
thank you
take a day
oh
yes
goodbye
oh
really appreciate you
really appreciated
brothers
hey
birthday
all right
that's right
my favorite a discontent
today
oh
my yeah
hurry up
oh
look at this
now
this
so
is
tv
now you say
hey
it again
i hope you had a good time
i want you to understand that this is
what democracy looks like
every single person out here is
beautiful your energy is righteous
and you're on the freedom side
i got some good news for you the freedom
side is the winning side
i said the freedom side is the winning
side
so many of us out here tonight
count every vote set it
see it see it
say it see it see
right
we're like literally
for too long people keep talking about
black lives matter but black men
who are in these communities are never
in these conversations
that's why we showed up this ain't no
damn party
this is our life this is
y'all we need y'all to understand that
even as the president's change
we need to be a part of that agenda
it's our city
we got our own money
put some respect on black man's name
listen y'all need a party for 12 hours
straight y'all make some
i want to say before we noise y'all go
tonight y'all have been beautiful
y'all see these beautiful black folks up
here you heard it loud and clear
you want to make sure in the same way
that they wrote up teeth when you roll
out
don't roll up by yourself protect
yourself don't go by yourself get you a
partner
get you a conway get you somebody to
walk with you to your car
to your house make sure you're looking
over your shoulder
all right make your brother's right here
wrong what you're doing
secondly bring all the art that you're
leaving behind we don't want to make the
mess
we don't want to leave our trash in the
streets there's trash cans on the corner
we're going to take care of our streets
take care of our city
also look out for tomorrow if you want
to keep the party going
same bedtime same bad location roll back
through here around 10 30 in the morning
and you're gonna get a little bit more
party got a little more fun and we're
gonna keep this thing rolling to every
vote
[ __ ]
oh
guys
all right
peace
we are collectively fill this country
you don't have this
i don't need you to have your payments
oh
right
highly medicated
this is the donald trump representative
is
this is our city we got over 400
homicides and when you live here today
we're still going to be here because
this is
all right
we know that we don't need to be
educated on that
oh
don't fight
oh
every day
is
oh
okay
hey
the other way
bring that feedback
alright
i appreciate it i've just been getting
questions all night
i learn every day
is
right
give us an even more jump
oh
oh
morning
twenty-five
all right
uh
the rain
okay
buddha
right now
so i'm state representative kelly
townsend and i just wanted to give you
an update
um what's happened today what we've
learned based on
uh some feedback that we got from the
county recorder from the president trump
campaign about a few different issues
okay
so last night we were shocked to find
out that
i was told by a staff member in here
that there was no
republican polling service right
remember that
yeah that was shocking we went into
action
and uh tried to find out what was going
on the trump campaign volunteer called
me today
and said if it was partially true
partially not true there was lawyers
there that are republican
and apparently one of them had stepped
away to make a phone call or something
so there were brief periods when there
wasn't a republican representative there
so i gotta tell you uh that's not
acceptable
but we're gonna make sure that doesn't
happen again i want to reassure
everyone that that has been corrected so
a little sunlight on an issue like that
fixes it right so
i want to encourage everybody that we
are not left alone to have
only democrats that are curing the
ballots and adjudicating those spoiled
ballots
so that's one thing the second thing is
i've learned that as a lot of you went
to check to see if your ballots have
been read and it was showing cancelled
i want to make sure you understand that
you can't have two life ballots
so if you signed up for early voting and
you chose to go to the polls and vote in
person
you are now issued a second ballot now
you have two live ballots
that's a no-no so they're going to
cancel your early ballot right so this
is going to show
liberal it's going to show cancelled
right
all right so anyway so just know that if
it shows cancel don't panic
and now if you vote day of and and you
give it to them and they put it in the
machine and the light turns green
that is your indication that it was
received
unfortunately that will not be on the
website to show you that you were
counted that's an issue for me and what
i'm going to be doing in the next two
years before the next election is make
sure that we can find a way that you get
some kind of hard copy receipt that your
ballot was received
if you're voting on the day of election
right because that's caused a lot of
concern
a lot of uncertainty and the last thing
i want is to have
voter confidence diminished so that you
feel like your vote doesn't count
and then so you don't vote at all we
want you to vote we want your vote to
count so that's another thing we need to
fix
is that if you're voting on the day of
that you get some kind of hard copy
receipt or
indication on the website how much is
that going to cost i'm not sure
that's what we got to look at in the
state of florida whatever it has to
happen to make that happen okay
and then i also i tried to explain you
guys last night but i think it was the
first thing we tried to do and everybody
was still really mad
i really want to make sure you
understand something that's really
important
in defense of the folks in this building
i've been on three tours in there
and they were very excited to show us
the new machines that they have in
maricopa county
the new machines are actually made to
accept
ballots with sharpie ink on them and
they offset
the the ones on the back so that if you
vote for somebody on the front and it
bleeds through
it doesn't over vote on the back and
reject your ballot so that was a really
great
improvement we were really excited to
see that we were expecting the sharpies
to not have a problem
and so whether or not sharpies are
causing a problem
is for the lawsuit to determine that has
been filed and i'm not going to try and
take that on i'm not an attorney i'm not
an investigator
i'm leaving that to the hands of the
courts to deal with that issue
do sharpies in maricopa county caused
your ballot to be spit out
that's one issue in other counties they
still have the old system and yes
sharpies will invalidate your ballot the
ballot itself
says blue and black ink right only
why are they giving
the question is why this election of all
elections because the
county got money to get new machines
they're new and improved there's
they're more secure if the ballot is
boiled
they used to have to fill out the entire
ballot if one race was spoiled they'd
have to fill out a whole brand new
ballot all the way down and someone else
would revoke for you
the improved part is they only have to
revoke for
the race that was spoiled so that and
then you have it
scanned and you know there's a lot of
eyes on it so i was
i was pretty impressed with what they
did what i'm not impressed with and what
i want changed is the forceful
you have to use a sharpie there's
nothing in the law that allows them to
have that level
of authority to make you use the sharpie
like the gentleman said blue or black
ink that was not coming from the
top somebody told somebody spread that
around i have enough of your examples to
know
that was widespread mandate it should
not have happened
we need to push back on that issue no
forced use of sharpies
and you better believe i'm going to make
sure that that is this
that i know i know i believe you guys
should not have had
balance as blue or black ink it says
that if you're going to hold them
accountable for anything it would
especially be you
can't make me use that pin taking pins
out of someone's hand
in the voting booth is is a sacrilege
right
you should not have done that that
whoever put that policy in needs to be
held accountable
that should never be a policy again hold
hold their feet to the fire
those folks need to be ready
i am hearing several voices at once i
can't process
okay so the question is what happens to
the ballot if it gets spoiled no after
it's counted
are they how do we know okay so here's
here's the issue i want you guys to
think as
americans right it would be really nice
listen up guys
listen up wouldn't it be really nice to
get a scan of your ballot
see how you voted and see that that was
what was locked in
that would make sense right the problem
is this
the problem is this anything like that
can be
hacked and then the most sacred part of
our elections is the secret ballot
and if you listen listen if you attach
your name
in any way to your ballot in any kind of
system that somebody could hack you no
longer have a secret ballot i myself was
just denied
a position because they didn't like my
politics in a completely different
unrelated thing
it doesn't feel good i don't want to
have to be discriminated against based
on my political beliefs the secret
ballot is super important
as much as we would like to have our
ballot scanned and blocked and all the
rest
so we're working on how to do that i'm
looking at things like blockchain
and other ways to do it if you're
interested in participating in that let
me know
and i'm happy to talk to you and find
solutions but right now
the secret ballot requires us is the
minute your ballot leaves your hand and
goes in
you no longer are attached to it there's
no bar code that's attached to you
and that's what has to happen so what i
want you to do is have some kind of a
paper or online acknowledgement that you
got that
not just a green light that you
visualize because a lot of people don't
know to look for that i'm going to start
taking questions
and please don't interrupt me because i
can't do several voices at once
this one here so what if you put your
ballot in the machine
and they didn't confirm for you a green
light or anything did your quote still
go through then why is it not showing up
still on the internet
question a good question if you put your
ballot in and you didn't see a green
light
and it's not showing up on the website
why how do you know it's been counted
that's
why i want a card copy to go to you
because if you didn't know to look for
the green light and it happened and you
didn't see it
there's no way for you to know if it
went through just so you know i
specifically
asked the poll worker that was with me
and she didn't answer me on that i said
how do i
she might not she the poll worker didn't
answer that question she may not have
known the answer hold on
but i don't
i i understand i i i wish i could answer
what you happened to your ballot i
cannot because that's how
this is how we're doing it right now so
we're gonna stop you know we started all
of this
and we didn't i don't know that we
prayed but i know we didn't do the
national anthem before we do national
anthem i want to see
hands of veterans everybody who's a
veteran can you come forward
thank you thank you thank thank you
everyone
thank you will you guys lead us
in the pledge of allegiance
take your hats off
one nation under god indivisible
with liberty
we're gonna say a prayer we're gonna do
another one
god we thank you that you've
allowed us to live in this great country
what a blessing and what a great time to
be alive lord
we have such a privilege to be able
to cast our votes to have them count to
believe in our system that believe in
our country god
we know there are those that are trying
to undermine that and we come against
that in your name lord
we want peace and integrity
and love in this country we that this
division that we're seeing we come
against that lord
we ask that you bring us together as a
nation one nation
under god not the red and the blue
nation
god we need you we need to restore
love for each other we need to restore
integrity for the system help us lord to
look and see what needs to be changed
show us god what we need to do to heal
this country
god help us to know whether everyone's
not going to agree on everything
but what we can agree is that we are all
americans
father we place our hearts before you
and we submit to your will and we ask
for you to heal this land
and that your will be done in this
election we thank you in jesus name
amen
i have a question okay another question
i voted by professional ballot like five
days ago and i got a receipt because i'm
supposed to be able to check it online
it says my ballot is not existing um
give that time
they've got millions of ballots i'm not
sure what the time frame is that might
stay on there i don't know how long
that's gonna take but you give it time
okay i'm going to give you guys another
website
i got something i mean another email
it's easy to remember
remember i was telling you yesterday
about the elections integrity unit
at the attorney general's office the
initials
e i u at azag.gov
if you have any concerns where you think
that there's an impropriety that's where
you email it okay
questions i would go to the county
reporter yes ma'am
thank you that's what you want to do um
i was just in an rnc and some of you
might have been at the rnc meeting
uh david bostie he came in town last
night right directly from the
president's office
and they said that they are going to
have a call team that if they want
anybody that has the canceled ballot
that what they're going to ask you to do
is go to the reporter's office
and say we i need to get a new vote a
new ballot
so do you know anything about that
because they said everybody yeah did you
come in late
about the cancel ballot issue if you if
you had an early ballot you were signed
up on a permanent early
voting list if you're signed up for that
and you chose to
vote in person that gives
and you said exactly where i was going
if you had an early ballot and you voted
in person and it says canceled that is
why
if you did not have an early ballot and
you voted in person and it says canceled
and there's a problem
and you said if that's the case you come
back to the recorder's office and you
request a new ballot
okay and you need to do it right and do
it tomorrow
why do they yeah on tape a county
election official
saying that the sharpie does bleed
through
okay the question is why does it say
that the sharpie doesn't bleed through
not to use it it was no it was said by a
county election official okay
okay well let me answer it and then he's
gonna clarify it okay
there's different counties obviously
here in arizona and different counties
do it differently
in some counties yes the sharpie
bleeding through
is going to spoil your ballot here in
maricopa county
that's not supposed to be the case and
then you want to clarify something
so so um in regards to that um
what you're referring to what he's
referring to guys is yes um last night
here at this elections office
um the woman who said she was you know
basically the supervisor on duty
her words verbatim when i when i
expressed to her hey
you know we were forced to use this
sharpie um she said well you were not
forced to the sharpie
there's no way you could have been
forced to use a sharpie well because
if you were to use a sharpie it would
have voided your ballot so we don't
force that
and and so that's that's it
okay if that's the video i watched today
with jennifer asking the question
i do need to say the woman wasn't
allowed to finish
what she was trying to say was that when
you
when you use a sharpie it used to bleed
through like i told you earlier
and it would spoil your ballot but she
couldn't finish what she was about to
say
was that if it does bleed through it's
offset and it shouldn't spoil it because
on the other side where the judges
remember the judges were on site too and
if you went through it wouldn't vote for
that judge it would be off on the side
somewhere
so it should it shouldn't spoil your
ballot if it did
if your ballot was spoiled you need to
tell me about that you need to tell the
attorney general
and then you can join the lawsuit if you
want to do that why why can't they do
it they would have told you in the
moment that your ballot was rejected
and then they would have gone to
adjudication for transparency sake
because there's so many questions about
this right
why not get 5 000 bailouts
do all sharpens okay just do it
and keep it live on tv and show
and count how many are accurate and how
many are
because that way if there's if there's
one
we know that there's there's a problem
if there's zero
and we have a decent sample why not now
that i mean that sounds like a great
idea
right now they got to get the whole
entire country's waiting
for us to get this done so we'll canvas
the results and then why not do that but
i don't
if i think the judge could stop them to
do that the
deadline tomorrow for the judge is to
tell them what we want to do
i recommend you reach out to the
attorney and make that suggestion
to have some kind of a quality assurance
test ran before we go any further
and that has to happen at the course
level these are our
but that doesn't give us 100 right here
so if you think that
that should do that should be
to talk to them and tell them your idea
okay who's that
okay so he's saying that they only
offered sharpies
that that's not any kind of violation i
mean it's kind of a bummer
if they're offering sharpies in maricopa
county
what does does it say no sharpies on the
ballot it says
blue and blue blue and black okay so he
says it says blue and black
ink only a sharpie's black ink no you
don't want to use
the problem exists and no so
providing you with black sharpies is
like i said it's a bummer
but the worst one is if they force you
to use those
things and that's what i keep pushing
that is not appropriate and i want to
know who put that policy forward
were forced to use the sharpies that's
what i'm talking about that's not right
that shouldn't have happened it's
somebody's policy i don't know who
implemented it and i'm looking to find
out where that came from
don't let that happen again that wasn't
right we should not have done that
machine i would be there right now to
stop it i don't
so what we have to do is find out where
it came from
i
are you going to do that absolutely i'm
in conversations with him i'm happy to
do that i encourage you guys to do it as
well
you can't just be me i have a question
over here
there any democrats here that are
concerned with their ballots being
canceled
interesting
to know who is going to okay held
accountable for all this and i also want
to know as far as the forcing of the
sharpies i do want to know and i'm
trying to find out
whose idea was it and why did they
implement it
we are going to continue to try to find
that out meantime
tomorrow we are going to submit this
idea to say
what recourse do these people have if
they were forced to use a sharpie and
they feel
like it somehow disenfranchised their
ballot can we prove it
i don't know that's for them to deal
with in court
yeah this is there's other issues
statewide and each county does it
differently
each county does it differently maricopa
has new machines it wasn't supposed to
be a problem
so this is this is what we have to find
out through the lawsuit
and we also want to thank you for coming
out
okay so they're telling me that's the
end of the questions they're gonna do
something
uh for you and i'm gonna hand it over
all right so right now
hey real quick
you're asking a question that's a valid
question you're asking
you're asking where's doug ducey at the
problem is he's not here
who is here right now who's the only one
that's asking these questions that is
fighting for you
who's here right now yes
senator elect kelly townsend make sure
you guys know that you guys know that
for
she does not have to be here she's not
being paid to be here this is not part
of her political agenda
now what we're going to do right now is
we're going to give of course a round of
applause please for senator elect
and now what now what we would like to
do if you guys will allow us we're going
to uh lead you guys in the national
level you guys go with that
and there you go
bursting
that our flag was still
there
foreign
love praying
usa usa usa
usa usa usa
usa usa usa
usa usa usa
usa usa usa
usa usa usa
usa usa usa
usa usa usa
usa usa usa
usa usa you guys sound amazing
you guys down amazing
hey guys so as we're being here tonight
we're gonna go through phases in and out
here
there's only so much we can talk about
because there's only one job we want
done which is the votes to be counted
and they're getting counted the good
news is look once again
you can only control what you can
control and you know who told me that
the daughter-in-law sandra day o'connor
was talking to her earlier
she said adele you can only control what
you can control
she also said wait for this to go to the
supreme court if it has to because the
supreme court will make sure it's right
so what i will tell you hey listen i
trust in our supreme court and i trusted
our justice system
okay it was built for a reason our
constitution was the most beautiful
thing ever put together
okay but hey as we go through the night
here we're gonna go through faces in and
out
but what i need you guys to do is the
message doesn't just stop
here the message starts on your phones
right now okay
you are warriors of democracy you're
warriors of freedom
you are warriors of a free election
right now and we need you to stand for
that
i need you to get on your phones i need
you to share i need you to tweet
i need you to peacefully please saying
we're peacefully standing outside
enjoying the night
waiting for the votes to be counted i
need you to let them know what we're
doing
because the media's narrative is not to
tell that we're doing that we are simply
here
we are leading prayer we are standing as
americans and you know what to all the
democrats out there and libertarians
we stand for you we stand for an honest
and fair election
and if he wins outright and fair god
bless america that's god's plan
but i have a feeling that those votes in
there lean towards president trump
because arizona is going to turn red
when those votes are counted
now with that being said as we're going
through here
grab some friends share some content
take some pictures
do some live streams keep the narrative
the same keep the language clean
because that's what we need to do to
move forward we're going to make an
example
the most beautiful thing i ever heard
was be the change you wish to see in the
world you guys ever hear that
i think yeah we all know that be the
change you wish to see in the world
and i think that go
i don't know ahead many of you are
serious with fox news
i am furious with fox news they have an
800 number you can call until they need
to take arizona out of the count for
biden
and the number it's right on you can
find it on their website
you can't get through eight eight eight
three six
nine four seven six two eighty eight
and call and email them if you can't
mail they're on their phones
i don't know they need to stop that
email go ahead and
if you guys can't get through but let
them know let me tell you guys something
let's make this clear about that okay
the media is owned by only a few a few
families it's pretty simple who owns the
media they're not like fox is separate
from cnn his own from warner brothers
they're all under the same okay they all
fall under line
so when i saw fox news caller there's no
surprise to me
okay journalism all the way around is
not being done the correct way it's all
about drama
and and click clickbait okay so we have
to understand that
we can sit here and yell at fox news all
we want but guys are you surprised
even the president has said himself he
puts fox news out there
we just need to demand fair journalism
okay but look
you get fair journalism when you give
them clean journalism
so when we stand here and we be the
change we wish to see
and we say we love america we love we
love our democrat brothers and sisters
we love this democracy we love the
libertarian brothers and sisters
we love those people that don't have a
party but you know what we love god
enough to stand here to make sure that
we
we respect the biggest and best empire
ever built in this nation and protected
by god
because one nation under god is how we
will stand
so and i think i think a lot of you guys
will look at
there's there's a few examples you bring
up blm for example example
you know i think all of us can stand
here and say we believe black lives do
matter
i think we all believe black lives
matter we believe white lives matter
we believe asian lives matter muslim
lives matter christian life matter
jewish lives matter
it doesn't matter all lives matter right
right but the thing is
we need to be the change you wish to see
in the world you can't preach something
and do the opposite
so where we need to stand is we're going
to stand here peacefully
we're not going to be enticed by anybody
driving by with the music blasting
trying to provoke anything
we're not going to listen to the media's
narrative saying hey are you guys going
to fight are you going to beat no
i'm just going to wait for this to be
counted and we want them to count it and
i love america and we're going to
protect this democracy
that's right and guys
i know trust me it's a more boring way
because it's ready to get in there be
like we're going to fight
but trust me this is eating them up
inside by the time you know it they will
be driving off because they don't have a
story for you
but why we're here is to put pressure on
those people i'm not worried about the
media
president trump's got enough media i'm
here to let them know we're outside
and we want you to do this right and
guess what just within the day president
trump seems now
inside is being reported over here um
we're inside
we're making sure it's correct so you
know what we're just out here enjoying
it
we're here to celebrate in whichever
which way we're here to respect it we're
going down that route
and so we need to respect our democracy
we need to respect our state
and you know what we can ask questions
about where governor ducey's at all day
but guys it's it's that conversation
that you have with that friend and you
wait for them to say
a certain answer and you're like come on
friends say that answer and they don't
give you that answer
you got the answer okay the answer's in
front of you
we've seen enough in 2022 you're gonna
have a chance to vote for governor at
that point again
it's your power at that point but what's
in our control tonight is to get on our
social media
it's to share the word is to call our
friends family brothers and sisters get
them all down here
and to make sure we stand for president
trump because i have never
seen somebody work as hard as president
trump has worked
for the country
so guys just to reiterate you know if
you're just joining us or if you've been
here all day or if
you were with me over at city hall or if
you were over at the gop office
just to reiterate you know we must keep
this a a safe environment
and we must keep this a peaceful
environment we know that it was peaceful
last night and the narrative
put out there you know by the media was
that you know we were forcing ourselves
in the building and and that we wear a
ride and we're causing civil up rest
but what we need to do tonight is say
that or we need to stay as far away from
those steps as possible
because as soon as you go up to those
steps they may
more than likely they're going to say
that you were trying to force your way
into the building
all right so we don't want anything like
that you know i i'm
you know right now i'm just one person
but i'm speaking for all of us tonight
you know and every meeting i'm speaking
for every one of you to say that we will
not be entering that building tonight
all right we will not be forcing our way
into that building
at all tonight tomorrow whatever
throughout the week and weekend we will
not be doing that
we're staying as far away from that
building you know as we can
but we still need it and we still have
the right to know these answers that we
demand and that we deserve
uh however like i said with that being
said we're going to keep this a fun
and a friendly and a safe and a peaceful
environment we are this is a peaceful
assembly i don't even personally i don't
even like saying that this is a peaceful
protest
because that word has been dragged
through the dirt all day long
you know all year long you know you have
all of these
negative protests and riots that are
going on and they say that those are
peaceful protests
i personally am saying that i have
peacefully assembling we that's what
we're doing we have the right to
assembly under the constitution but we
ask that you guys just do it
over here and away from their stairs so
the narrative does not get twisted
our narrative is this that we just want
the answers just like my brother right
here was saying
all we want is the answer we want to
know when those votes are counted that's
all we don't we don't
we're not going to attack anybody we're
not going to hurt anything or any
buildings
that is that is a no go and if you are
if you if that is your plan
we don't need you here um you know
that's not the narrative
our narrative is to simply have a fun
and a friendly and a safe environment
and we are going to peacefully assemble
get out there and mingle as he was
saying get out there mingle
share share share you know get out there
um
share this everywhere that you can every
you know facebook post instagram live
uh snapchat whatever you've got get it
known
you know so that way these people need
to know there might be people that
aren't technically savvy if you live in
a retirement community and
that your neighbors are maybe getting a
whiff of this and they're not on the
smartphone game
get them involved let them know hey you
may or may not be being cheated but they
all have the right to know
and every voice matters every vote
counts
and it should be counted but we need to
ensure that we are a safe
and that we are a peaceful group of
people so let's just keep it peaceful
tonight
hey guys yeah i'll answer that um
one question that was asked is tomorrow
morning charlie kirk and the students
for trump
are putting out an event here at 10 a.m
i suggest
getting here early it's going to be busy
tell your brothers your sisters or
friends or families
we're here to stand for democracy guys
we're here for a fair and honest
election
so they're going to be here tomorrow to
push that it's going to be exciting but
let me tell you guys something
i love when we get powerful people
coming in but the powerful
the powerful people are in front of me
right now okay i'm staring at the
powerful people
it's not good governor ducey can walk
down here right now and i don't that
doesn't change my thoughts on
anything because i care about we the
people we the people of the united
states of america
okay so that's where we start that's why
i'm asking you to call your brothers
your sisters or friends and your family
and get them out here because this is
the change we will create the change
and you know what we force pressure on
there and we've created change already
in there
and now things are being protected and
things are being watched and we're going
to get our answer
and guess what god's plan is going to
give us the answer that we want to hear
as simple as that
i will tell you guys something i want to
shift over into
um i was affected when you talk about
what's happened in this election i think
why we all stand here
is you look at everything that's uh
touched or had any sort of effect on
this election you talk about big tech
right everybody familiar with facebook
instagram
yeah i don't know if you don't know but
those are the things you can't talk
about anything conservative because then
they kick you out
i'll be correct you guys everybody raise
your hand if you know what i'm talking
about
what you're talking about there we go so
i was a shadow band on there two months
ago after we led child sex trafficking
rallies
they took us off a lot of people didn't
see my post my share was went down
i've built a new social media platform
i've been working four years at it's
called pivot it will come we will get
there
but let me tell you why it didn't happen
it hasn't happened because when we go to
get the money we need
people say you can't compete with
facebook one of the richest guys in
arizona told me that
i've had vcs in silicon valley i love
your idea but you can't compete with
facebook
that is not america america wasn't built
on monopolies
now the issue is people say well they're
free they're private company they can do
what they want they can monitor
their speech if they want to you're
you're right in the sense that
zuckerberg can choose what he wants but
the issue becomes when the anti-trust
kicks in
and you don't like companies i'm not
saying i have the answer i like the
belief so
but when we create something and we want
to compete
and you're going to come crap on us and
say oh we're going to see you for 30
million
because you stole this and that can you
afford to fight it and you can't say
bye-bye to your startup thank you for
your technology have a good day
now that platform that allows people to
speak on has been shut down
that is what we call communism okay that
is a communist act you can tell me you
can act how you want as a company but
then you have to respect the policies of
america
which is to allow competition if you're
scared of competition that means you're
doing something
i'm not scared of competition i'll take
it on all day but this is where we're at
right now guys
so i'm excited now let me tell you
something i find it kind of funny that
not only did i get shadow band they
don't allow me to post stuff about my
social platform on there
they're familiar but the funny thing is
mark zuckerberg also gave 400 million
dollars
to a non-profit for election workers and
to rent
poll places okay do you guys understand
what that means
mark zuckerberg in a 50 billion dollar
industry the 50 billion a year i'm sorry
50 billion year that at least they do
if you were to be told hey this
president if he gets reelected they're
going to repeal 230
they're going to come crack on you
anti-trust is going to be right up your
alley
you're going to have more competition
i'm sorry guys but if you had a 50
billion
company don't you protect that yeah you
do anything you can to protect 50
billion dollars
because once you get up there that green
looks really really nice okay
and that's very very powerful so
when people talk about them being a
private company that's fine
facebook can exist but what we need is
we need a fair
and equal democracy we need a fair and
equal
competitive market and that's where
we're headed and that's what's
frustrating with this so we saw big tech
get involved
or they're shunning us then we look at
big media a lot of you said shame on fox
news this and that guys
honestly you're wasting your breath
media is all ran by the same amount of
people
okay are you surprised the narrative is
the same all they've done on fox news is
give you three people you like
and the rest of the show's biased the
other way so congrats you've been fooled
by them congrats pat on the bus
that's news there's a lot of news max oh
yeah there's a lot of different ones but
at the end of the day is we want fair
and honest reporting
okay so big media has done a great job
in pursuing
this and then you talk about what's
happening in the polls
there's a lot of things coming out which
wisconsin's trying to clarify there's
been more votes than voters registered
in certain places
we want answers to that we're not a
conspiracy theorist we simply want
answers
to why this is coming to fruition i'm
not an idiot
don't play me to be an idiot and if you
give me a fair and honest answer and you
say this was done right
and you say joe biden was the winner i
say god bless hopefully this next four
years can be great and the 2024 we're
back
but something inside of me says
something is very off
and we're going to continue to fight
which is why we stand here for president
trump tonight
but beyond that we stand here for our
children we stand here
to protect this land go ahead and pump
it up
your children one day your children and
where we're at in society is going to
ask you this
because this movement that we have on
the left of social democracy
let me explain you guys social democracy
i'm going to take you guys a little bit
more of your taxes
we're going to give you a little bit of
what we think you need and we're going
to go down that route to make sure
you're comfortable
but your innovation your creation your
hard work your want to build
the reason why everybody wants to come
to this country hasta luego
okay i don't know if you see this let me
let me put this in and
and and simple terms for you guys who
has ever heard of russian oligarchs
okay there's russian oligarchs right
those are the big billionaires that sit
with putin
and then there's just everybody else in
russia well guess what you're looking at
the bill gates the mark zuckerbergs
and you're looking at the mike
bloombergs okay those are the oligarchs
of america if you keep watching this
happen
and that's what's going to continue to
happen and and it's funny because the
left
claims were against billionaires but why
do the biggest billionaires support the
left
that's right if they really want to give
it away
99 they want to give away 99 of your
wealth bill gates we'll give it away
today what are you waiting for
what are you waiting for till you die
bill gates give away your wealth what
are you waiting on buddy
people are starving and dying right now
bill gates if you really cared about
society
give it away right this second we're
waiting on you because there's a lot of
homeless people here in arizona
there's a lot of homeless people in san
francisco where your company has an
office out of
mark zuckerberg where you bought your
whole neighborhood and have all this
land around
why aren't you helping those people mark
that's how we know something is off
so guys as we stand here tonight we're
not standing here just to get these
votes counted
we're standing to protect the democracy
we're standing to protect the greatest
nation ever built and our kids
but what i want to go down is guys we at
the social democracy part
and i really want to talk about this
because i think it's something we
overlook okay
it's something that we don't rationalize
a lot of us see the viewpoints on the
right and why we believe
president trump should be in office but
let me tell you
when we go down that route and our kids
grow up and they don't have control over
their education
and they're being told where they need
to go and how they need to go and we're
only told hey these are probably the
jobs you can have and here here's the
here's the health care you can get
even though you work harder than that
other person over there hey
you know when they start controlling
that they've now controlled you
and when they control the education
education system they control your brain
and they control your brain good luck
you're now robots you're all asking
about when robots are coming it's
already here
you're being trained you're being you're
being you're being
manipulated they ai the algorithm on
facebook
if i wanted to trim you do you like
chocolate
chocolate or vanilla chocolate okay i
bet you anything give me three days with
the ai algorithm on facebook and
you're gonna love vanilla i promise you
not even a question that's how powerful
social media is that's how powerful tech
is
and we have to understand that if we
continue down this route it's not that
we don't want a second party it's not
that we don't want a third party a fifth
party
it's that we're not going to go from the
top the peak where they teach you in
school capitalism
we're not going to go back we're going
to keep this a capitalist country
where you come here you work and you can
make anything you want to of yourself
come on put it together guys come on
and at this point that we stand it's at
this point where we take a stance
where i'm telling you our kids will look
at this
and their lives will be forever changed
in 2020 and even 2024. i will put it
there i always believe 2024 will be the
most
powerful president we ever left but
don't get me started on that that i will
say that i'll tell you why
in 2024 whoever we have take over at
that point is going to be the crucial
thing of either continue what president
trump's been able to do
or we're going to progress and so when i
look at it guys
we're at a point where our kids one day
will say mom dad
uncle aunt grandma did you stand up for
our society
did you protect my opportunity you know
what's funny i have these buddies they
both played in nfl they were both on my
football team they made me look good
one was a wide receiver one was a
running back played for the steelers and
the buccaneers
and he said to me he said adele we lived
in south phoenix and he's like you know
what was awesome
is we were able to uh we were able to go
to mountain point now with tukey i don't
know if you guys are familiar with our
tukey
that's where i went to high school there
they call it all white tukey that's what
it's named as
but these guys from south phoenix comes
over right they did their thing
they worked hard they got their
education they went on to play in the
nfl
they said no we got we got out i said
how'd you make that happen they said
well we made a choice that our other
friends didn't make
and we got out of south phoenix and with
president trump
telling you you have a school choice
yes my friends that i watch
growth
that's just the seven o'clock drop
there's supposed to be another one at
nine o'clock
but that's good so it's it's not bad
news it's good news he's still in
the hunt nothing is over at all that was
a positive thing and we just have to
wait
now for more ballots to drop in a couple
more hours that was good
how much
is
thank you excuse me
excuse me
i have seen not necessarily
um
um
our
um
i appreciate it
um
um
i appreciate thank you
ago
um
when you give up two years
is
oh
oh
you want america to know
uh
i
one of them
is
uh
um
oh
hey guys
americans
i
all right